hi I'm Ryan and I'm David and we're
doing an instant trailer review for the
new Godzilla which is not starring
Matthew Broderick which is not starring
Matthew bra I mean among see cameos if
you've seen the 1998 version then you
know that you don't want this to start
Matthew brother just a few facts about
the film stars Aaron taylor-johnson
mostly Walter White Walter White also
known as Bryan Cranston to the people
who probably know and love him elizabeth
Olsen who's gonna play Scarlet Witch in
the New Avengers it was directed by a
guy named Gareth Edwards who made a
movie called monsters which is a monster
movie that he made for five hundred
thousand dollars and it's incredible in
a summon instant watch and you should
all watch it right now after you watch
our trailer review anyway David let's
not bury the lead I don't want to be the
guy who loves everything but I love this
trailer yeah so much it's haunting yeah
it is David's roof Aaron is a you know
high ranking military officer um I
really think that that's our
intelligence in there I think that a
trailer starting off like this there's
almost a minute long extended sequence
of this halo jump and it's pretty
amazing yeah goes up a lot of tension
because you're sort of like why are they
jumping out and they are sure well like
they're higher than I thought they were
and there's a shot of them in the clouds
coming up that's just absolutely
gorgeous and haunting I think that the
thing that struck me the most about this
trailer here there's that shot that's
just like we're just scored a shot and
it's also like really evocative because
it's like is the lightning because of
Godzilla it's possible goes Alaska why
me maybe he messed up those own layer
with this it's possible breathing fire
so there's our first shot of destruction
um my butt city that is it looks like
San Francisco maybe cuz there's that the
needle I don't know I don't want it you
know what I don't want to go on record
as saying it's anyone city ever since I
said that New York was Pittsburgh in the
dark knight rises trailer review anyway
these things cut deep people but um the
thing that strikes me the most about
this trailer to use a film school term
like the texture of the world in it is
is really really great this point of
view shot is so cool and generally kind
of brings
from a video game perspective yeah and
it's gonna be in 3d which is amazing
there's our kind of first look at the
Basel we can kind of see a little bit of
an outline we have the sort of jagged
rock yeah so you can see his like you
know his his kind of Godzilla's
signature Stegosaurus back kind of thing
and also it historically he's known to
have lightning go up the back and then
shoot fire out of his mouth I don't know
how in this giant monster movie I don't
know how realistic they're trying to be
with the monster we also don't from this
trailer we still don't know where he
comes from or like what he does but
that's I mean that's sort of what builds
the sort of tension I'm gonna get as his
beast where do you think he came from
David I think because of the
behind-the-scenes pictures I've seen
where um they're like like the to aaron
johnson is like around a radioactive
site I think maybe someone to do with
that yeah that's kind of historically
what he's always kind of man and not a
nother and Johnson Godzilla well we were
at comic-con they had a whole
godzilla-like experience setup which was
really cool it's a cool kind of
marketing technique that they had where
they set up this whole like like noodle
bar that had been like attacked by
Godzilla and it was really really cool
experience so this is bryan cranston
where's the back of bryan cranston and
then we see kind of the the build-up you
know there's a little spittle so and if
we could just anyway um so they kind of
have these they start from when
Godzilla's already attacked and go back
to like what seemingly is the beginning
of like people realizing something
catastrophic is happening that right
there like it was Sally Hawkins who's
been in like rock and roll issues in a
movie called happy-go-lucky really good
actress
now do you think that's a missile turn
use to shoot Godzilla I just shares I'm
again going for an Oscar oh now that's
like such a signature like disaster
movie shot that's a real Spielberg touch
is like someone just turning slowly to
wiping off camera I'll tell you what it
works every time and this okay yeah very
1980s atilla add this shot we're like a
that's the metlife building oh my gosh
then we should be worried what if this
whole movie doesn't take like there's
nothing New York about it what if it's
all just maybe the west coast I mean
it's possible I mean yeah cuz of Japan
exactly it was Ray absolute Enna's well
that is I mean like would have ran love
the Pacific now oh you don't mean the
movie you mean literally the Pacific Rim
yeah um I kind of hope that's the case
and I think New York could use a break
from the destruction movie exactly and
um maybe it'll be a global kind of thing
yeah let's hope so um or maybe it'll
just be a handoff like do you think that
they'll try to tie this into the 1998
Godzilla we're like he's one of the egg
spoiler alert miss Godzilla's one of the
eggs from Madison Square coryell II hope
so because when I was great I wanted
that sequel and I thought King Kong vs
Godzilla that's I was like definitely is
the number one movie that people saw
when they were 80 awesome and then saw
again it was like oh no yeah there's
elizabeth awesome again um just pointing
her out so this is like the gray hairs
award we're going to hear the roar and
they showed this this at comic-con like
two years ago or some kind of version of
this but I like that you could like you
can almost feel the dust David and they
use the the old war
it's so cool we could see you saw a
pretty good outline there yeah David
right now this is my most anticipated
film of 2014 oh I know you have
transformers or the captain america
movie yeah that also looks good but I've
i'm really i'm a huge fan of garrett at
gareth edwards first film and I've been
kind of waiting for him to do something
else since then so this is very exciting
and I also love monster movies yeah and
he's we have the this the more classical
upright Godzilla rather than the
Tyrannosaurus Rex PS roland emmerich
Godzilla now from behind the scene
pictures we saw it do we see mafia at
one point I remember there's not
something we saw something that looks
like a dead monster on a beach they
didn't show that in the trailer but I
remember seeing some picture if there's
more than one monster in this I think my
head's gonna explode because yeah would
be I mean if they're thrown it all out
there I mean it's hard of the Pacific
Rim the movie where like you had these
like suits fighting monsters David if
there's giant robots in this movie my
head yeah if they just made Pacific Rim
like if I went to Godzilla and Pacific
Rim yeah the characters from Pacific
gray like it was just it just said
Godzilla the beginning in the Pacific
I'd still be happy so you really can't
lose with Godzilla but let us know what
you think of the Godzilla trailer and if
you're excited to see another iteration
of the classic mom's yeah and West year
what are you looking forward to in 2014
just not even moving life personally you
know is problem coming up there's a few
things you graduating I don't know
comment below let us know all the things
until next time I'm Ryan thank you for
watching